aquí tenemos representadas dos economías
diferentes a la izquierda tenemos una
economía en la que la producción de
equilibrio a corto plazo se encuentra
por encima de la producción con pleno
empleo por lo que hay una brecha de
producción positiva esto parece ser algo
bueno porque la economía marcha
realmente bien e incluso se produce más
de lo que es sostenible pero esto
también representa aspectos negativos
puede haber un agotamiento de recursos o
podemos comenzar a tener incómodos
niveles de inflación en estas
situaciones si no tiene lugar un
mecanismo de corrección que nos devuelva
a la producción con pleno empleo el
gobierno puede querer implementar una
política fiscal restrictiva política
fiscal restrictiva esto también puede
deberse a que una política fiscal
restrictiva puede anular alguna política
fiscal expansiva implementada con
anterioridad hablaremos más sobre esto
pero cuáles pueden ser ejemplos de una
política fiscal restrictiva bueno pues
podemos aumentar los impuestos
eso reduciría la demanda agregada
también podemos disminuir el gasto
gubernamental y si te estás preguntando
qué pasaría entonces con estas curvas la
respuesta es que la curva de demanda
agregada se desplazaría hacia la
izquierda porque el objetivo es volver a
nuestro equilibrio a largo plazo
entonces llegamos a esta curva de
demanda agregada ba2 por medio de una
política fiscal restrictiva ahora bien a
la derecha tenemos el escenario opuesto
aquí tenemos una brecha de producción
negativa también conocida como brecha
recesiva los gobiernos tienden a ponerse
más nerviosos con las brechas recesivas
porque entonces la gente está sin
trabajo y las cosas no marchan bien en
estas situaciones si no tiene lugar un
correcto mecanismo de corrección el
gobierno puede querer implementar una
política fiscal expansiva vamos a
escribir la política fiscal expansiva
el objetivo sería desplazar esta curva
de demanda agregada hacia la derecha
luciría más o menos así para volver a
nuestro nivel de producción con pleno
empleo esta sería la demanda agregada 2
de a 2 y cuáles son algunos ejemplos de
una política fiscal expansiva
bueno pues va a ser lo opuesto entonces
podríamos disminuir los impuestos
o aumentar el gasto gubernamental
pero concentrémonos en esto las
políticas expansivas y profundicemos un
poco en las cifras supongamos que
tenemos una economía en la que nuestra
propensión marginal al consumo pmgc es
0.75 vamos a escribirlo y supongamos que
aquí tenemos una brecha producción
negativa de 100 mil millones de dólares
entonces tenemos una brecha de
producción de 100.000 millones de
dólares pensemos primero en la
herramienta aumento del gasto
gubernamental toda esta propensión
marginal al consumo cuánto tendríamos
que incrementar el gasto gubernamental
para cerrar una brecha de producción
negativa de 100 mil millones de dólares
pone en pausa el vídeo y trata de
averiguar lo bien pensemos en nuestro
multiplicador
nuestro multiplicador vamos a escribirlo
será igual a 1 sobre 1 - la apm gc
entonces esto es 1 sobre 1 - 0.75 que es
uno sobre 0.25 lo cual va a ser igual a
esta es la brecha de producción de 100
mil millones de dólares que queremos
cerrar y va a ser igual al aumento del
gasto gubernamental por el multiplicador
que en este caso es 4 si dividimos ambos
lados entre 4 vamos a obtener que el
aumento del gasto gubernamental
va a ser 100 mil millones divididos
entre 4 lo cual va a ser 25 mil millones
de dólares tiene sentido si el gobierno
gasta 25 mil millones de dólares debido
a la propensión marginal al consumo y
tenemos un multiplicador 4 entonces en
esta economía va a haber 100 mil
millones de dólares de gasto total
debido a ese gasto gubernamental inicial
de 25.000 millones de dólares pero qué
sucede si en cambio el gobierno quiere
cerrar la brecha mediante la disminución
de los impuestos qué cantidad
necesitaría disminuir para cerrar esta
brecha de producción vamos a tomar como
base este modelo muy simplificado bien
aquí tenemos que analizar el
multiplicador fiscal nuestro
multiplicador fiscal es igual a la
propensión marginal al consumo por el
multiplicador vamos a escribirlo
y en este caso va a ser el negativo de
la pm gc porque si aumentamos los
impuestos el gasto gubernamental va a
disminuir y viceversa entonces esto va a
ser igual a menos 0.75 por 4 que es
igual a menos 3 otra manera de
plantearlo es si queremos cerrar una
brecha de producción de 100.000 millones
de dólares tenemos que multiplicar del
tate que es cuánto aumentaron los
impuestos por menos 3 y para obtener del
tate dividimos ambos lados entre menos 3
entonces del tate es igual a 100 mil
millones de dólares dividido entre menos
3 lo cual es aproximadamente menos
33.000 millones de dólares una vez más
porque es un número negativo
bueno pues porque del tate es el aumento
de los impuestos y si es negativo
significa que los impuestos disminuyeron
en 33.000 millones de dólares entonces
los impuestos disminuyen en 33 mil
millones de dólares
ahora bien aquí podemos ver un par de
cosas interesantes además de la mecánica
y las cifras observa que este número y
este número no son iguales es un error
común pensar que deberían ser iguales
porque estamos tratando de cerrar la
misma brecha pero no es así en general
si damos por sentado todo lo que hemos
asumido para cerrar la misma brecha de
producción tendremos que cambiar los
impuestos por más de lo que tendríamos
que cambiar el gasto gubernamental nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo